notes to start don't forget to take a
look at our new channel visual academy
the population was besieged by the
mongolian army of the golden horde some
of the soldiers among the asian troops
were already sick i'll leave you the
link in the description so
let's get started
[Music]
when we talk about large armed forces
and armies we usually focus on cases
such as the united states
china or russia beyond that it's a
stretch to come up with more contenders
perhaps those of the united kingdom or
france and those countries barely
feature in the struggle for power and
hegemony in the 21st century but what
about india
after all india is the second most
populous country in the world and very
soon if it is not already it will be the
first and it's not just about population
by area it is also among the 10 largest
countries in the world
specifically it ranks 7th
[Music]
moreover in one way or another its
economy is booming
or so many investors hope and more and
more companies are setting up production
plants there
tesla to set up electric car
manufacturing unit in southern india
reuters
apple ramps up iphone and ipad output
shift to india and vietnam
nikkei asia and keep in mind because we
tend to forget about it but when we talk
about india we are also talking about
one of the nine nuclear powers in the
world today although there is no
official confirmed data its arsenal is
estimated at around 150 nuclear warheads
and yes
although it is often overlooked india
also has its own geopolitical clashes
and disputes
including its own clash with the great
asian giant the people's republic of
china
you see the two countries that india has
the most problematic relationship with
today
are pakistan and china the main focus of
the conflict is in the region of kashmir
a region shared between pakistan and
india with a small part
also in the hands of the chinese giant
so in this area india keeps two flanks
open
on the one hand against pakistan which
new delhi accuses of sending militiamen
across the provisional border to
destabilise the indian part of kashmir
and
on the other hand against china with
whom it shares a border in the galwan
valley that
from time to time becomes the scene of
armed clashes and tensions
likewise india and china as we have
already told you one visualpolitik share
an unfriendly mountainous border in the
himalayas and also have conflicting
interests in the indian ocean an ocean
where we find an increasingly
expansionist china that tries to take
control of the area by building naval
bases while india
seeks to strengthen its navy to ensure
its trade routes
[Music]
however despite being a demographic
giant a rising power in the making and
having two conflicts with two nuclear
powers
india the world's leader in bureaucracy
far from having developed a powerful and
fearsome army as we might expect has an
armed forces riddled with problems
and that is not the only issue in the
areas under dispute with its neighbors
the country also lacks good overland
infrastructure
such as roads and railroads which
greatly hampers supply chains and the
potential deployment of troops in the
event of a conflict however all this
could soon change
so what role does india really play in
the new power struggle that is
developing in the asia pacific region
how does new delhi hope to compete with
its northern neighbor are we perhaps
witnessing the beginnings of a new kind
of cold war
between china and india listen up
when size does not matter
unlike china russia and other major
emerging military powers india
never had a deeply rooted military
tradition when the country ceased to be
a british colony in 1947 the british
left behind no established military
culture and no strong internal security
or
intelligence structures in fact the
situation did not change much
after independence was achieved
successive indian governments considered
the lack of economic and social
development to be a greater threat than
any posed by the country's neighbours
and of course if we're talking about a
poor and densely populated country you
can imagine the makeup of its armed
forces traditionally the indian army has
always been very dependent on the number
of troops leaving the issue of equipment
modernisation in second
or third place therefore although india
has the third largest military budget in
the world
after china and the united states its
operational capabilities in practice
are very limited you could say that the
configuration of the indian army is more
reminiscent of the armies of the first
half of the 20th century than
of modern armed forces
now let me explain india's armed forces
are currently composed of
1.5 million troops according to analysts
and military strategists they need to
get rid of at least 200 000 to 300 000
men and divert the surplus resources to
improving battlefield weaponry for
example
investing in modern artillery light
attack helicopters and fourth and fifth
generation air capabilities
then in addition to over staffing and
shortages of equipment and weaponry
there is also the problem of military
pensions to give you an idea almost
30 percent of the defense budget for
2021 goes to paying military pensions
that's almost 18 billion
out of a total budget of about 62
billion
[Music]
in other words the indian army
practically spends more on military
pensions than on the acquisition of new
equipment in fact if we subtract
military pensions from the budget then
india's position in the ranking of
countries by military spending
falls from third place to ninth and is
on par with countries like south korea
but of course with almost 1.5 million
soldiers to pay
train prepare and equip yet these are
not the only problems facing the indian
armed forces
the country has also had serious
problems in trying to achieve the goal
of developing a strong military industry
of its own and this is precisely one of
the missions that the current government
has set for itself
obviously having a strong military
industry allows a country to be much
less dependent on the international
geopolitical situation when it comes to
buying military equipment
and that also makes you less vulnerable
if you depend exclusively on purchases
in the international market
and especially if you are overly
dependent on one country
and suddenly a conflict occurs you can't
get involved without risking what would
happen to military supplies
now this is the current situation in
india but what are they doing about it
what are new delhi's plans well let's
take a look
building an armed force from scratch
for some years now the indian government
has been focusing on the weaknesses of
its armed forces you could say that they
seem to have realized that they are
neither efficient
nor modern nor would they be up to the
task in case things go wrong with china
or even pakistan that explains why a
15-year modernization and restructuring
program was launched in 2012 due for
completion in 2027. we are talking about
the long-term integrated perspective
plan
or l-tip it's a plan that anticipates
the purchase of 250 billion dollars
worth of modern weaponry during that
period but which has nevertheless been
suffering cuts and constant delays over
the years
even so although not all the deadlines
and goals set so far have been met
there has been some improvement in
indian military capabilities by sea
land and air let's take a look at these
improvements starting with the navy
india aims to have a force of 200
warships and 500 combat aircraft
operational by 2050 which would make it
one of the strongest navies in the world
however at present
it only has about 170 ships 17
submarines and just over 200 naval
aircraft
they are therefore still far short of
their goal amidst its current equipment
it has one aircraft carrier the ins
vikramaditya which
is a soviet aircraft carrier purchased
from russia in 2004. it is also
developing native aircraft carriers with
the aim to incorporate two or more
vessels before the end of the next
decade just out of interest
approximately 60
of current indian military equipment is
of soviet or russian
origin particularly submarines aircraft
and armoured vehicles but back to the
navy in addition to the aircraft carrier
it also has 11 destroyers
13 frigates 23 corvettes seven
reconnaissance ships
15 conventional submarines one nuclear
submarine and a ballistic missile
submarine as well as other smaller
vessels
well this is the current inventory but
the question is what is to come
in addition to the two new aircraft
carriers mentioned before the plans for
the navy include
24 new submarines including six nuclear
powered and six diesel electric
submarines with advanced air independent
propulsion systems which will allow them
to stay underwater for longer they will
also acquire seven new frigates and five
support vessels among other minor
acquisitions but perhaps the real news
comes when talking about what is
expected to be added to the army and
air force you see the modernization of
the indian army involves the
incorporation of 464
russian t90 tanks in addition to the
2000 tanks
already in service the aim is to operate
some 3000 russian tanks of this type and
to have them replace the older tanks
such as the soviet t-72s that are still
in service
but it's not just tanks improvements are
also coming in the field of artillery
with the development of long-range
artillery guns and greater mobility that
will allow
indian weapons to reach targets on the
border with pakistan from greater
distances for example up to 145
m777a2 howitzers will be procured from
the united states
a total of 100 south korean k9
self-propelled howitzers
and native atax atags howitzers are also
being developed
then to protect military and nuclear
bases along with cities and strategic
infrastructure india signed an agreement
with russia in 2016 to deploy the
russian s 400 anti-aircraft defense
system one of the best anti-aircraft
systems in the world
[Music]
the adoption of the s400 could give
india a decisive advantage over pakistan
making it practically impossible for any
pakistani plane drone
helicopter or missile to attack indian
territory we're talking about the
deployment that
yes has not sat well at all with the
united states a country allied with
india which even threatened sanctions
for
a 2017 law that punishes the purchase of
this type of russian equipment
india's friction with the united states
rises over planned purchase of russian
s 400 defense systems new delhi did not
have a wide waiver
from a 2017 u.s law aimed at deterring
countries from buying russian military
hardware
cnbc in addition in 2017 india signed a
2 billion
contract with israel to equip the indian
army with a regiment of 16 launchers and
560 israeli barak 8 missiles oh and they
will also add 22 us apache attack
helicopters which are considered one of
the most lethal machines in the world
and after reviewing
the changes in the navy and the land
forces it is now time to turn to the air
force
friends although india is the fourth
largest air force in the world after the
united states russia and china it is not
exactly the most cutting edge
it currently has 806 fighters 82 special
mission aircraft
seven refuelling aircraft 232 transport
aircraft 652 helicopters and 325
training aircraft and if that already
sounds like a lot the iaf
the indian air force intends to add more
than 400 additional aircraft
to this end the iaf has just added 53
new sukhoi su-30s to its fleet so that
it now flies 272 aircraft of this
russian model it has also signed a
nearly 9 billion dollar contract with
france for the purchase of
36 dassault rafale fighters these two
models are capable of carrying different
types of missiles
including nuclear-capable missiles such
as the indo-russian brahmos
in addition to the fighters there are
also new early warning and airborne
control systems as well as a new
satellite network that india already has
in operation we are talking about
satellites such as the risat 2.
and a kind of lookout satellite
specially designed to monitor pakistan
24 hours a day
and this long list that we have
described only covers the most
significant programs but i think the
idea is clear
it seems that india is getting down to
work on a major modernization of its
armed forces the country wants to stop
being a paper tiger and become a feared
and fierce fire tiger but it's going to
take a lot of money to complete its
plans and for the time being the truth
is that india has not put much money
into its defence programs in recent
years and that means that many of these
plans are being developed in
more of a piecemeal fashion than as an
integrated program to improve
operational capabilities
for example between 2000 and 2019
india's defense spending relative to its
gdp
fell from 2.45 to 1.49
and although it has now rebounded
slightly to 2.18
if we compare it with china's
approximately two percent and taking
into account that china's gdp
is five times larger than india's we can
see the significant gap between the two
countries
for their part many defense analysts say
that india's 15-year plan which expires
in 2027
lacks strategic sense that is some of
the arms acquisitions may not be well
targeted to actual needs in the event of
war
[Music]
of course perhaps india's great strength
its great bit
is the deterrent capability of its 150
nuclear warheads but that does not mean
that it is questionable that
despite having an annual expenditure of
more than 60 billion dollars the country
can barely aspire to play any regional
role
will india manage to change the
situation and see its budding desires to
become a powerhouse field we can see
that for the time being as you can see
the modernization plans continue to
advance
albeit slowly local production is not
taking off either the government has
signed co-production and co-development
agreements with the united states
israel and russia through the make in
india scheme but it does not seem to be
enough
not to mention the bureaucratic hell
that is india and how that affects
production chains
in any case only time will tell what the
outlook will be in a few years time the
wish lists are on the table along with
all the shortcomings and difficulties as
well and now if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like and
subscribe to visualpolitik best regards
and see you next time and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear even
more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there